e
[Música]
não dá para fingir que não é com você em
2021 diversos relatórios foram
publicados mostrando que a nossa
dependência da biodiversidade chegou ao
limite crítico a perda de biodiversidade
e as mudanças climáticas pelo afetar os
negócios EA sobrevivência das pessoas
especialmente as mais vulneráveis
relatório global de risco publicado pelo
fórum econômico mundial o relatório
fazendo as pazes com a natureza
publicado Pelas Nações Unidas e o
relatório sobre a economia da
Universidade publicado pelo governo da
Inglaterra deixar bastante claro que
essa dependência cada vez mais crítica e
é preciso começar a medir o quanto nós
dependemos da natureza o caso contrário
nós podemos levar um susto lá na frente
quando descobrimos que não dá mais para
continuar sem a biodiversidade e com
clima sendo alterado Como está sendo eu
diria que das várias crises que nós
temos enfrentado de uma crise econômica
sanitária com a pandemia da covid-19 Nós
temos duas coisas fundamentais que estão
por trás disso tudo uma crise de
biodiversidade uma crise climática que
se por um lado quase em todos os
problemas que nós temos enfrentado por
outro lado também traz uma série de
possibilidades de inovação e de soluções
para enfrentarmos o problema e potência
da biodiversidade o último relatório do
painel internacional de biodiversidade e
serviços ecossistêmicos mostrou que 47
por cento dos ecossistemas estão
alterados em declínio ou seja estão
sofrendo tipo de degradação que vem se
acumulando pelo menos desde os últimos
200 anos o resultado disso é
é um quarto das espécies do mundo hoje
ameaçada oitenta e dois por cento das
espécies conhecidas com o número dos
seus indivíduos a sua abundância
diminuindo e está infectado populações
tradicionais indígenas e já reportaram
Segura esse tópico relatório que isso é
de setenta e dois por cento dos
ecossistemas que eles usam e nos quais
dependem foi de fato alterado durante
vista climático o problema é ainda pior
e isso é chamar a atenção da Comunidade
Internacional por isso tantos acordos
internacionais e tantas discussões a
respeito do que fazer com a mudança do
clima desde o acordo de Paris quando a
ideia de que se não podíamos ultrapassar
1° e-mail em relação ao período
industrial até o final do século essa
ideia tem avançado e os países tem se
comprometido a reduzir as suas emissões
de gases de efeito estufa que é o que
causa Esse aumento da temperatura do
planeta
e entretanto nós já sabemos que vai ser
muito difícil ficar dentro desse um galo
e-mail atualmente estamos em um ponto um
de aumento e é muito possível que
chegamos ao final do século com 2° mas
chegar com dois graus de aumento em
relação período pré-industrial
significa catástrofes reais do ponto de
vista de incerteza de água onde trinta
por cento dos dos locais do planeta vão
sofrer com eventos extremos como nós
temos visto como chuvas extremas secas
extremas estão mais significa um
problema de segurança alimentar falta de
alimento 2° em média de aumento do
planeta significa até dez porcento das
passagens globais perdidas por mudanças
dos ecossistemas e os animais que ali
vão estar isso sem falar nos Riscos que
isso traz para cidades só com problemas
anunciados por mutações possíveis devido
a mudança e há uma Estimativa de quase
doze trilhões de dólares que seriam
gastos para conter seus efeitos
e o problema maior sobre nós mesmo não é
hoje mais ou menos 1,2 bilhões de
pessoas dependem diretamente de
ecossistemas naturais só que boa parte
desses ecossistemas estão degradados há
Dois Bilhões de hectares degradados no
mundo inteiro só no Brasil são 69
milhões de hectares degradados
logo parte da nossa tarefa é recuperar
isso recuperar 350 milhões de hectares
degradados no mundo é uma meta global de
grande a missão que foi traçada
internacionalmente o Brasil se
comprometeu recuperar 12 milhões de
hectares dentro dessa meta
isso é importante porque a restauração
desses ecossistemas eu que funciona para
as duas queridas quando eu restauro
ecossistema eu consigo trazer
biodiversidade de volta e eu consigo o
número de processos que fazem controle
Universidade desaparecer e por outro
lado eu consigo ajudar o problema do
clima capturando o carbono reduzindo a
emissão garantindo que gastamos
ecossistemas saudáveis que fazem o
balanço correto do que nós precisamos
para o planeta sobreviver Então essa
restauração de ecossistemas pode reduzir
o risco de extinção de espécies estudos
recentes mostram que só no Brasil mais
de mil espécies poderiam sair da lista
de risco de extinção caso nós
restauração desses 12 milhões de
unidades então não pode ser prestado 18
milhões de toneladas de carbono
equivalente só na Amazônia e na Mata
Atlântica que são os nossos ecossistemas
florestais por natureza e eles têm
consequências também para nossa economia
uma economia que pode gerar centenas de
milhões de reais por exemplo
economizados com tratamento de água o
nosso protegemos as nascentes e deixaram
os cargos não seja Temporada até chegar
nas estações de tratamento
e nós já temos estimativas aqui no
Brasil de organizações da sociedade
civil que mostram que essa cadeia gerada
pela restauração pode gerar cerca de 191
mil empregos rurais diretos aumentando o
PIB não só pelos empregos mas para os
produtos e serviços que ela gera em até
2,6 trilhões de reais
nós estamos falando que a restauração é
uma solução baseada na natureza que tem
um enorme potencial de crescimento no
mundo inteiro e também no Brasil isso
envolve por exemplo o funcionamento de
um mercado de carbono o mercado Onde
você consegue através de ativos da
natureza
atrair investimentos para que nós
possamos alavancar essa restauração
natural
se desenvolve por exemplo a emissão de
títulos verdes de finança que são
basicamente maneiras como empresas
Ou organizações têm para captar recursos
e pagaram certo nível de investimento a
partir de um empreendimento que vai
trazer alguma mudança do ponto de vista
da biodiversidade e do clima
Empreendimentos verdes por assim dizer
mas que poderíamos ajudar a fazer uma
transição para uma Economia mais
sustentável isso geraria o imenso valor
e Impacto positivo para essas empresas e
isso faria com que nós gastar seus
membros por meio de soluções baseadas na
natureza que soluções são essas são
soluções que usam o que a natureza faz
para resolver os nossos problemas
então toda a parte de restauração que
vai trazer uma solução para o problema
do clima é uma solução baseada na
natureza a construção de parques
lineares nas cidades ao redor de é
também uma boa solução porque as árvores
que estão na máquina desses rios contém
inundações com têm problemas de
tratamento de água e são capazes de
filtrar boa parte da poluição que
chegaria até o que isso é voltado
bastante inclusive porque do ponto de
vista do setor privado toda discussão
sobre
SG ou a asg em bom português que são
diretrizes que visam atender critérios
ambientais sociais e de governança tem
crescido isso quer dizer que cada vez
mais o setor privado vai estar atento a
investimentos que podem acontecer
oriundos de projetos ambientais e
projetos sociais de novo a restauração é
uma boa saída para casar essas duas
letras da sigla SG tanto a parte
ambiental contra a parte social
a boa notícia e nós estamos fazendo isso
o Brasil já tem inúmeros projetos de
restauração até hoje mais de 74 mil
hectares foram restaurados na Mata
Atlântica um dos nossos biomas mais
degradados
historicamente 113 mil hectares vem
sendo restaurados na Amazônia esses dois
BIOS florestais por natureza o que falta
é acelerar e da escala essa restauração
Ainda precisamos de planejamento e
capacitação de pessoas de Assistência
Técnica Rural que ensino produtora fazer
essa restauração e o real engajamento
dos produtores um convencimento de que
isso é não só bom para natureza para o
clima mas é um excelente negócio para
ele e para isso nós precisamos de
financiamento financiamento incentivo
aos produtores para que comida
desenvolvimento e pesquisa nós possamos
monitorar o verdadeiro Impacto que nós
vamos ter sobre a restauração da
natureza e agora é o momento de agir
Nossa dependência da natureza nunca foi
tão grande e nunca foi para o Claro para
nós o quanto nós dependemos disso a
crise de 2019 trouxe para nós a certeza
de que se nós não cuidarmos do meio
ambiente algumas coisas que nós nem
conhecemos podem aparecer e vamos afetar
de forma direta é hora de agir é hora de
agir do ponto de vista ambiental é hora
de agir do ponto de vista climático eu
acho que a restauração dos ecossistemas
a recuperação daquele que nós degradamos
é um excelente caminho e não precisa ser
caro que vai trazer benefícios
econômicos e que fundamentalmente vai
trazer benefícios para a nossa sociedade
e para nós mesmos
E aí